recently there was an article in the
financial times the financial times was
talking all about the epic historic bull
market investor psychology and risks and
potential sell-offs they were making the
argument that actually we've only lived
in a bull market and that there is tons
and tons of risk that assets could turn
over very quickly there's a number of
investors that also started to tweet and
be like look all the young people
they've never lived during a market
downturn they continue to say that they
don't understand how to underwrite risk
they don't understand how to weather
that asset sell-off they're all pointing
to last friday as that sell-off that
made them think about it so i went and i
did some analysis and what i did is i
looked at people who were graduating in
2009. if you graduated college in 2009
you're approximately 35 years old today
now if you look at that group of folks
what you find is that they have actually
in my opinion lived through more
financial duress than any other
generation in history what do i mean
well if you graduated in 2009 you walked
into one of the worst job markets in
history literally there was people
losing their jobs left and right no one
was hiring a lot of those folks had to
move in with their parents on top of
that you saw family and friends all
losing their jobs getting completely
wiped out financially there was mass
chaos it was not called the great
financial crisis for any reason now 2009
was not the only thing it took until
march of 2010 for people to actually
start to get private job growth so for
an entire year people who are graduating
in 2009 were sitting on the sidelines
could not find jobs it was very very
difficult you can see here that it
wasn't until 2010 when people actually
started hiring again now that would be
bad enough if you started your career
during a global financial crisis but
then of course if you think of last year
march of 2020 asset prices were selling
off due to the covid concerns the
uncertainty the fear the doubt that was
in the market we saw gold go down over
10 we saw stocks go down 25 to 35 and we
saw bitcoin go down 50 in a single day
it was a recession there was two
consecutive quarters of negative growth
so quite literally people who graduated
in 2009 have lived through two separate
recessions in a 12-year period on top of
that last year there was over 6.5
million people a week that were losing
their jobs unemployment reached almost
15 percent we watched people have to run
businesses or live and work at
businesses that could not operate this
was the hardest business environment in
the last 50 years the government forced
you to go home and run your company
while you sat at home locked away
without your freedom to go to your place
of business and operate as you had been
so not only did those people live
through the global financial crisis not
only did they live through the 2020
recession and the lockdowns but on top
of that most young people have actually
invested in bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
and if you look at that since 2011 there
have been three times over 80 percent
drawdowns in the price of bitcoin
since graduation people who are about 35
years old have lived through three
separate 80 plus percent drawdowns but
let's give people the benefit of the
doubt let's say that most people were
not invested in the market until 2016 or
2017. if you were invested in 2017 in
2018 a year later you lived through an
80 plus percent drawdown in the price of
bitcoin other assets outside of bitcoin
in the crypto market drew down 95 to 99
there has never been a time in the
entire stock market that stock investors
or boomers or people older generations
had to live through at 85 to 99
drawdown in assets the single largest
most severe bear market that anyone in
the legacy market would have ever faced
but it's not just about that 2018 bear
market let's say that you weren't even
invested then and you just invested at
the beginning of 2021. if you're a young
person and you invested at the beginning
of 2021 there have been six separate
times this year just in 2021 that you
have weathered a 20 plus percent
drawdown in the price of bitcoin
including a 37 drawdown in september and
more than 50 percent dry down in may to
july so the whole idea that young
investors haven't lived through bear
markets they don't know what a market
downturn looks like is completely wrong
in fact the truth is that the young
investors they have diamond hands
eighty-seven percent of people who owned
bitcoin was seventeen thousand dollars
in 2017 held it all the way down to
three thousand dollars they were buying
more young investors are built different
they're digital native they understand
volatility most of them have a high
degree of their net worth tied up in
assets like bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
that have 80 volatility
they were built for this environment
the older generations the legacy
investors the stock market investors
they can't handle this volatility young
people were built for it they were built
in it and they are best prepared to
continue to invest in this asset so not
only have young people lived through
multiple bear markets and multiple
market downturns in the last 12 years
but on top of that they are used to much
more volatility they are used to much
bigger drawdowns there's not a single
investor in the stock market that
wouldn't run and cry to the government
and ask for a bailout ask for monetary
or fiscal stimulus if the stock market
went down 54
over three months if it went down six
times in a year over 20 percent they
literally would be crying foul they'd be
asking for more circuit breakers they'd
be saying something is broken in the
market they'd be asking for the federal
reserve chairman to be fired they can't
handle the volatility that young people
can young people understand the world
has changed but older people will
continue to point out the young people
and say they don't know what they're
doing they're completely confused